What we found was that first of all, pilots look for their
reserve handle along their skeleton.
So if they're rotating forwards, their hand naturally goes to
their hip bone. If they're rotating backwards as
they would in the SAT on auto rotation, they go a bit further
down their thigh. We also found that one of the
best pieces of advice I was given by a senior doctor was
don't just do something man, stand there.
So the opposite of the don't just stand there, do something.
It's the idea of take some time, soak in what's happened, think
about your options and make the right decision psychologically.
It's also been shown that if you're able to integrate the
experience and understand why something happened, then you're
less likely to find it traumatising.
Doc, I have heard your name time and again at various places and
you know, one thing that has come to my mind a lot of times
is that Physiology of the art of light is kind of very different
from the Physiology of usual sports.
So what I'm wondering is that how important is the the
physical aspect in paragliding, even though it is not a very
physically demanding sport as we look at it?
I think it's a really interesting question because a
lot of us come from a sports background and so when we think
about training for anything, we think, right, I've got to go for
a run, I've got to lift some weights, I've got to do all this
stuff. And when we're in the air, we're
still subjected to demanding conditions.
You know, often it's cold or it might be a high altitude or
there might be G forces. We might have to run hard for
take off, but the kind of loading on the body is
different. You know, it's kind of light on
the legs but very heavy on the brain.
And so the way I think about it is that Physiology is important
because it sets us up to make the right decisions and do the
right things. And optimizing Physiology kind
of makes sense because if you want to fly well, you want to
get your brain in the best possible state.
But it's not kind of like it would be if I'm going to run a
marathon where I need to just be actively training my my heart
and my legs. OK.
I just want to look at it from a business perspective because
this is something that I experienced myself very
intimately. And the thing was when I started
seeing the world from above, which is a completely different
perspective, which you're not used to because obviously
commercial flights does give you that maybe a little bit while
take off and landing, but you're just a spectator.
You're not controlling the aircraft.
There's no decision making. But the moment you start doing
that in your first few high altitude flights, it's a lot of
processing that your brain has to do.
So the the cognitive function of the brain is, is there a certain
period of a paraglider's flight or, or like the learning where
the cognitive brain is adapting to this brand new sensory input
that the eyes are giving it and that's why it's using more than
the usual energy that it would once you kind of settle down and
this becomes like once you don't get goosebumps every time you
get in the air basically. I think that's such a good
question and there's so much you can pick apart.
So I guess I think about this quite broadly initially.
It's like, what's the context in which we're flying?
Because I'm always thinking about how can we do it better or
safer or, or more enjoyably, You know, it's all our hobbies.
So most importantly is that we're, we're having a good time.
And so when we think about going flying, you know, if we're going
flying for one day, then that's going to be a different set of
demands to if we're going flying day after day after day in a
comp. And you kind of feel that in the
cognitive loading, don't you? Like you feel the fatigue over
the course of days. Sometimes somebody's think, oh,
I actually need a day off to, to clear my mind.
The other thing, as you point out, is the kind of the idea of
bandwidth. You know that when you, as you
say, when you first fly, you get goosebumps and you can't really
think about anything else. But as we start to automate our
actions, as we get, you know, the flying part, you know, when
you're a beginner, you're just consumed by which string do I
pull and how do I land where I need to land.
When that becomes less consuming, then you start to
think more about the world around you, about thermals,
thinking forwards in terms of what needs to happen next, and
also thinking back in terms of how you can draw on your
experience. So to my mind, it's almost like
the, you know, I can't necessarily say that we like we
grow a paragliding cortex, but what I think we do is we shift
the act of paragliding to different parts of the brain as
we progress. So the sort of actions, the
physical actions, you know, get shifted to more of a
subconscious part of the brain. You know, the, the kind of
movement patterns will get embedded in, I suppose, less
kind of cognitively demanding parts, opening that up to some
of the, the bigger questions. The other kind of interesting
thing that you said there though, is, is that the brain
needs more energy. And this is kind of a, it's kind
of an interesting fallacy, which is the brain uses 20% of our
energy. That's kind of a fact that we
know. But thinking hard doesn't
actually use that much more like the energy that the brain is
using is is really just trying to kind of maintain it in this
constant state where all the nerves are just busy shifting
around potassium, sodium and doing all the things that they
do. But we all know that if you've
got to think hard to do something cognitively demanding,
then if you don't eat that day, you're going to do worse.
And we also know that if you work really hard at something
all day, you get fatigued and tired.
And So what that's really about is avoiding big spikes in blood
glucose. So if you're eating regularly,
you're keeping yourself hydrated.
It's not that the brain needs extra energy and you're giving
it that extra energy. It's you're keeping a really
nice constant energy environment for it to draw on.
And I think that's important because when people are flying,
sometimes it's tempting to like not eat for a while or to wait
until you're tired or wait until you you feel like you need to
eat. But actually by just eating
regularly and often, even if you're not thinking that hard at
the beginning of the flight, for example, you're just kind of
chilling and cruising waiting for the comp to start, what
you're doing is maintaining that really nice constant energy
environment. So there's always a nice even
supply of glucose in your blood. There aren't big spikes or big
crashes, so the brain can just draw from it as it needs.
Is there a certain food or type of food which is the most
optimal brain fuel which you can intake during a strenuous like
cognitively heavy activity? So I think it's really about two
things. First is just the
practicalities, like something that is practical to eat in the
air. But the second is, you know,
kind of to your point at the beginning, like this isn't
normal sport where you're burning tons and tons of
glucose. So smashing like an energy gel
or, you know, loads of sugar or other things like that, that's
probably more likely to create spikes.
So my take on it is actually you want kind of complex
carbohydrates, so things that are broken down relatively
slowly. So, you know, kind of bread or
cereal bars or things like that. That's kind of that's probably
the scientific answer, but I know for a fact that sometime if
I'm about to do something a bit stressful, then a few Haribo
seems to make me feel better. And I can't really explain that
by biochemical means, but I know by experience that that is what
I crave at that point was an M&M's.
So I think the scientific answer to your question would be
complex carbohydrates that are easy to eat in the air.
The practical answer is kind of what makes you feel good at that
point in time. That's yeah, like because feel
good factor is the bottom line, right?
Like if it feels good, then it's like whether it's placebo or
not, but it's going to make you believe that it's good and
you're kind of more likely to sail through that thought and
eventually make it happen. I think so.
I guess one of the things that this draws on is that it's quite
hard to give paragliding specific answers based on the
science. And I try, and I've tried to do
some of the science, but if you think about it, paragliding is
an incredibly complex activity. It's complex cognitively, but
it's really complex environmentally.
And so kind of classically, when you study stuff, you measure
something in the Physiology like a drop in oxygen saturation and
then you do some cognitive tests like, you know, can you do a
puzzle faster or more accurately?
And then you generalise what that will mean for behaviour.
Now in a really simple task that is a chain that's quite easy to
make. But in paragliding, you know,
it's something that paragliding could be a top to bottom or it
could be a competition over 100 kilometres, or it could be
acrobatics. It could be somebody who's a
beginner, somebody who's incredibly experienced.
It could be somebody who is feeling calm and chill or
somebody who's had no sleep the night before.
It could be somebody at the start of the season, at the end
of the season. You know, all of these things.
The variation in within individuals and the variation
amongst individuals means it's quite hard to give definitive
answers and it's just quite hard to study.
And so, and also because there aren't very many paraglider
pilots, that means sample sizes are quite small.
There's also not tons of money in it.
You know, I've done all my research kind of on the side as
a hobby really, because I love the sport and I enjoy doing the
science. But it means that we don't have,
say, the huge banks of data that we would have in running, for
example, or football. So I guess all the answers that
I'm going to try and give during this and all the conclusion I'm
trying to give doing this are the best collection of thoughts
and ideas I've had drawing on all this other literature,
sports stuff, environmental Physiology stuff, bit of
military things, you know, all of these things I'll try and
bring together. But I was a great big pinch of
salt on all of my answers because none of us really know.
But we've just got to try. I think even the manufacturers
which probably make the most money or let's say the software
people like such instrument manufacturers, even they are not
in it for making huge amounts of cash, but like the amount of
satisfaction it goes. So regardless of how small it
is, there is something that it gives back which is so valuable
that kind of keeps all of us in as well.
Oh I couldn't agree more. I've not been able to fly for a
few weeks. I'm already getting frustrated
and I'm already missing my flying friends.
I couldn't agree more. But I'm more talk about the
cashier in the sense that sadly research is a job like any other
and so researched and to go where the money is.
So when in these small niche sports, it's really hard to get
stuff done that is directly relevant.
I was thinking from the perspective of, let's say, a
pilot who wants to go out and make it big.
And when it comes to because I don't know if competing is
inherent when you're younger, because a lot, a lot of
conventional sports kids starting from pre teens to
getting into competitive circles and then investing all in, of
course, for the help of whatever support system they have.
And then reaching a fair bit of high level of exertion, mental,
physical, like all kind of training by the late teens.
And that kind of sets up a very solid foundation for them to
peak or be in a position to peak when they are in their mid 20s
or something. And then some of them get on to
be legends or those kind of things.
I do remember Russ Ogden saying that paragliders peak around the
age of 30 and probably I think one of the main reasons for that
could be that monetarily the sport is very heavy and it needs
you to be a bit more stable in your life before you can start
going into it. But I'm like, if there is a late
teen, preteen or early 20s pilot listening to this and they want
to go out and chase the glory as hard as possible, what would be
the ideal body type, training type and fuelling?
Because if you as a researcher who has all of these resources
is saying the data set is fairly small, then these people who
just have a dream or with a vision are basically layman and
their only reference points is the small bits and pieces of
media that gets put out in short form or long form.
So I feel like, and that was one of the reason why I started the
show actually, because I wanted, I had so many questions which I
just could not find an answer to.
And that is why I'm trying to figure out if we can give our
audiences, I wouldn't say a mantra of some sort, but some
sort of a baseline that all right, if you want to make it
large or do it in the most professional way, then this is
where you should aim for when it comes to performing physically.
Yeah, no, I see. Exactly.
See where you're coming from. That quote from Russ Ogden is a
shame because I started paragliding a week after.
My first, I'm going to have him on the show soon, you know, so
we talked about that, so. I think it's interesting, isn't
it? Is the question, is there
something that is inherently important about being young,
being in your teens and 20s? Or is it simply that just gives
you so much exposure to the sport compared to somebody who
starts later and has all the kind of life you're now chatting
different podcast about how life happens whether you want it to
or not. And so you know whether that's
the challenge. And so it's interesting to think
about. Certainly younger people acquire
motor skills much faster. We all know that, but I'm
curious how much of it that is a factor.
Or simply that they can just spend their summer doing it, or
their parents are into it, or they've been exposed to it.
It's a good question. To answer your specific point
though, like where would I point people?
I think Physiology is a relatively small component.
I think my view on it anyway is that what is probably going to
get people the furthest is consistent goal setting.
And Malin Log at Flyyo has done some great stuff around this,
really effectively setting goals and working out ways to achieve
them. And also I think the sports
psychology side of things, Kriegel started winning when he
started working with sports psychologists.
Because once I think you've mastered the basics of pulling
the strings and once you've got better at thermaling and
gliding, the psychological component becomes so huge that I
think starting that early on and developing very good
psychological habits is probably an important route to success.
In terms of the Physiology stuff though, purely I would think of
it in terms of margin. If I think about my worst days
in the sky, there are ones where I've exhausted myself on the way
up to launch because in Scotland we've got to walk a lot.
I'm dehydrated, I'm tired, I'm worried, I'm out of currency,
the conditions are marginal. Those are the things that I
guess would set me up for failure as opposed to success.
So when we think about how we might flip that around in terms
of performance, you think, OK, you need enough general fitness
that the act of getting to launch and getting ready is not
going to be an exhausting or barrier to your day.
You need the right kit. So because that helps you
getting up there, getting set up, you need to make sure you're
sleeping well. You need to make sure you're
well fed and hydrated, as we've discussed, need to make sure
that you've not been drinking or smashing a load of drugs the
night before such that your sleep has been disrupted and
you're hungover. You need to think about things
like sun protection, cold protection.
All of those things, I guess are about giving you margin to fly
your paraglider well and to make those good decisions.
OK. I just quickly want to touch up
on the topic of ideal body type and I think as a reference
points we can take racing paragliders in a World Cup
because obviously we can't just have all the other scenarios
where you are a beacon flyer or you're going on a trip or like
the acro competition. So let's say you are a pilot who
is racing in a cross country World Cup and ideal body type.
Of course, the glider sizes, the ballast and everything is a
whole different story. Which.
I was going to say, I think the ideal body type is just being an
absolute unit, isn't? It I think a lot of us saw that
meme slash photo which Baptiste posted when they put a limit on
the ballast that you cannot ballast more than 32 kilograms.
And Baptiste posted a photo of him Maxime and Honor and with
like huge ass protruding bellies coming out and saying that is
how futurist leads are going to look like.
I don't know because Formula One, yes you do lose a lot of
water or 5 kilograms or something like that.
And I per race and I remember Horan saying that he also loses
up to a few kilogram after a race.
I'm just wondering, is an ideal body type someone like Horan or
can they be a bit more muscular because of the amount of G
forces that we go through? Or can there be a more stronger
core because of the amount of the the core usage in, in those
kind of scenarios? And of course, in our pre show
notes, we exchanged the lower like benefits or lower heart
rate and like avoiding the heart rate peak surges during the
stress periods or something like that.
So what? What's your take on that?
I think one of the nice things about paragliding is that it's
pretty democratic in terms of the body types that it will
accept compared to something like the high jump.
I guess I think all of the points you allude to are things
that could be helpful under certain circumstances.
So having being someone who naturally has more G tolerance,
which has a little bit to do with the heart reflexes, a
little bit to do with the gap between heart and brain, and
also a little bit to do, as you say with musculature.
That's something that might be helpful if you have to do a
spiral dive, but it's also something that's very trainable
and it's also something that's overcome able through equipment.
So for example, like a drogue sheet.
The the other stuff I think is probably just dwarfed by size if
you're really talking about competition and your ability to
fly the largest possible glider for all the aerodynamic reasons
that we know. Beyond that, I don't think there
is an ideal body type and I think that's a great thing.
I think that's something to actually to be celebrated about
our sport. And I personally would love to
see rule changes in competition, which I know are difficult to
do. And I know lots of people have
tried it through the wait lists or through the pool needle
discussion or all of these things such that irrespective of
your size, you can compete on a level playing field.
And also I think that having to carry ballast is one of the most
dangerous and unnecessary things that we do because the
artificiality of what we have created.
If we think about paragliding generally, like most people
think, if you say paragliding, it's that thing where they pull
you behind the boat. So no one really knows what it
is we do. And lots of people in
paragliding don't know who the world champion is, let alone my
mother. So I think we've got this really
niche thing. And so we have the opportunity
to make this really niche thing what we want it to be.
And so creating an environment where if you want to race at the
highest level, you have to fly a harness that is uncredibly
uncomfortable, makes you sweat, the tail wraps around your face
when you stall, that if you're a small pilot, you have to carry
30kg of ballast. That is a genuine health hazard,
I would say on take off and on landing.
To me that feels just put it kindly, like a wasted
opportunity. There are ways of putting it
less kindly. So I personally would love to
see us work together as a group to make it I guess both more
more inclusive and also just more enjoyable for everyone
involved. Because as you say, there are so
few professional pilots that for most of us this is our hobby.
Why are we making competing at our hobby actively unpleasant
for quite a large proportion of the people that do it, and
actively risky? But I'm also not a very
competitive person, so I accept that other people have different
views on that. Yeah, of course when it comes to
competing, there is a certain aspect of our sport of pilots
which are like, yes, the more crazier, the better, the more
fun. And then there's a rational
side, which is let's be obvious guys.
Well, I quickly want to touch upon the environmental side of
the sport, that of course there's one thing that you can
feel right that you can have a certain like controllable, such
as the equipment and the laws and the rules and everything
which kind of make it like that. But then there's a certain bit
of, what do you say? Like what nature throws at us.
And a lot of times you are flying in situations which are
new, which are out of the ordinary.
And usually one thing that I can say is that wind factor is such
a huge thing in paragliding that it it surprises you more often
than not. And there have been so many
times that I've gone up in the air and I've ended up with
frosties on my fingers and I've had to like leave the risers and
bring them back and warm them up.
So when it comes to dealing with the environment, what is the
biggest risk that you can be exposed to if you're not very
well prepared for it? Because being prepared for
something like that is only experience and experience comes
from trying and getting to know about things.
So it's, there's no ideal way to go out and saying that, yes,
this is how I will do it unless you've actually done it a few
times. And then they're like, no, OK, I
need to fine tune it a bit. So I totally agree with you and
many people would say this because it's my passion or my
profession, but don't underestimate these
environmental factors. I think we have a tendency to do
that. If we think about the
environmental factors that can affect us, they're really oxygen
level, cold G force and sun exposure.
I would say like those are the main ones.
The oxygen thing is interesting because I've flown a lot in
India. It's my favorite place to fly.
I was fortunate to fly in Pakistan a few years ago, and
that was wonderful as well, and to go up nice and high.
Undoubtedly lower levels of oxygen affect us.
They affect our ability to think.
They affect, in some cases, if it gets low enough, our ability
to see effectively in terms of our peripheral vision.
All of those things narrow. They affect our ability to
control the glider. And they also have a bit of a
hangover effect. So if you get hypoxic and then
you go down to a low altitude, you feel better, but you're
still not back to 100% for probably up to about 90 minutes.
For those wondering what's hypoxic?
So hypoxia is low levels of oxygen in the blood.
Technically the term for that is hypoxemia.
But I would think about it as we're in an environment when we
fly high where the pressure is low.
That means that the oxygen molecules, there's still 20%
oxygen, same as there is at sea level, but they're all further
apart. So that means to get the same
amount in, you have to breathe faster, which is why actually
flying at house 2 is so dehydrating, because what's
happening is you're breathing in and out lots and you're shedding
water each time you do so that that's one of the reasons why
it's dehydrating. The other reason is because the
oxygen levels are lower. Your kidneys don't work as well,
so you don't conserve water in the same way, which is why you
desperately need to pee when you fly at high altitude or in cold
environments. So oxygen's definitely a thing.
It's hard to know what height it starts to matter at because that
depends quite a lot on different people and it also depends on
and by different people. Climatisation, sorry, genetics
and fitness. It also depends on
acclimatisation. We talk about that in a SEC.
The there's a very easy way to fix it, which is to carry
supplementary oxygen. But there's also a lot of
associated faff that comes with carrying supplementary oxygen.
But I can only say from personal experience that when I flew
within Pakistan, when I switched it on, suddenly my mood
improved. I felt warmer.
I could think more clearly. I almost felt like I could.
I don't know if I could physically see better.
I just felt less blinkered. But I felt a striking increase
in bandwidth. So it's changed my perception a
little bit in terms of I knew academically that hypoxia was an
issue. It's first, it takes a while to
really feel it, and then when you feel it, you're like OK.
Or when you feel it going away or improving with oxygen, it
strikes you how much it might be affecting you.
What are the first symptoms that come to you that you can
understand? Because as we spoke about in the
beginning of the show, that it's such a cognitively heavy load
and there's so much to look and observe and be constantly
thinking that it's so easy to be drifted away.
So how do you identify that this might be coming in the next
10-15 minutes? This is why your point about
experience is such a good one because everybody has their own.
It's called a hypoxic signature. And so if you're a fighter
pilot, you get put in a chamber, you get made hypoxic, and then
you get a load of puzzles and other things to do.
And there's some brilliant videos of all these, like
incredibly macho U.S. Marine pilots, just like mashing
like kids toys together. It's fun to watch.
But the purpose of that training for them is both to realise that
they don't know they're impaired, but also to try and
work out exactly what you said, like how did they feel in the
the time leading up to that impairment?
Because it varies. And so finding our own hypoxic
signature as paradelight of pilots is a little bit difficult
because we don't have access to these chambers.
But I think one of the way to do it is to really try and be
observant of yourself when you go into these environments.
So if say I'm in beer, I'm going over the back and flying up
above 4000 meters. I'm asking myself what am I
feeling? What can I see, what kind of
thing? And actually, because I was
quite interested in this, I put a little note on my cockpit to
remind me to think about what I'm thinking.
Because you can get so in the zone.
But typically for people, they would say things like mood
changes. So you either feel pretty
euphoric or you feel a bit sad or a bit constrained or a bit
afraid. Not having as big a bandwidth,
some changes in motor skills, so you're not thermaling as nicely
as you would normally. You're bouncing in and out.
Then as you get more hypoxic, the way you communicate with
others might be a thing. So sometimes people become less
commutative, sometimes that become quite garrulous,
sometimes they start talking a bit of nonsense.
Certainly if that's happening, it's too late.
But that's also the advantage of flying with buddies because they
can point out to you that this thing is happening.
Obviously, the most kind of telling sign that it might be
happening is just the fact that you are high.
So taking a note of your altitudes and think that OK, I'm
now entering A vulnerable place and I would say probably about
for most people because this varies a lot between
individuals. Once you start flying above 3000
meters, certainly 3 1/2, you are going to be subject to this.
All right, let's say how many minutes above 3000 because a lot
of times we are, I wouldn't say exactly dolphining.
You're getting high, lower, high, lower depending on the
glides. So when do you start hitting the
point of no return that OK, now I'm pushing my limits and then
high box, yeah, is a very real thing now because I've been
doing this for like past two hours.
So again this no evidence specific to paragliders, but
that I guess the aviation like general aviation would be above
10,000 feet for 30 minutes or above 13,000 feet for any period
of time. So I don't know what 10,000 feet
is that about 2802 thousand 600 meters, something like that.
But that's the general aviation guidance.
But it's so individual, like if you're again, if you're tired,
hungover, dehydrated, your tolerance is going to be worse
if you're acclimatized. And a climate like where the
paragliding is acclimatizing or not isn't really known.
But the thing that is most acclimatizing is the altitude at
which you sleep. So if you sleep at high
altitude, you know, a little bit higher than normal or closer to
the altitude at which you fly, then that is going to help you
tolerate the hypoxia. The really interesting 1 though,
for me though is cold. Because when we think about
hypoxia, we're thinking about supply what's available in the
atmosphere, but also demand how much your body is using.
And it's that balance or that lack of balance that creates the
problems. And if you start shivering, your
oxygen consumption goes up by about five times.
And oxygen is being used to keep you warm.
And if you can make sure that you're stay nice and warm and
you certainly don't shiver, then I think that's one of the most
helpful things you can do to give yourself more margin when
you're flying. You're in a hypoxic environment.
Doc, I want to talk about accumulated fatigue a little bit
here because it just hit my mind that yes, getting hypoxic once
in a seven day period or 10 day period might not be as dangerous
as it would be if you did that on a repeated basis.
So from what I see is that as we mentioned in the beginning of
the show as well, that there are times when your body is
screaming for a bit of a break and your brain also says that
I've had too much of it and I want to switch off and think
about something else. But specifically these kind of
scenarios which can be life threatening very quickly because
of course, if you're hypoxic and you get asymmetric, which is
more than 5060% and it requires your quick reaction thinking
pulling out the reserves or like anyways, in that thin air, there
are a lot of variables that can go wrong.
And I don't want to talk about Murphy's Law right now that, but
it kind of gets pretty scary pretty quickly.
So let's say, how does accumulated fatigue look like in
paragliding even though you are trying to do everything right
and you're trying to play within your limits before day seven of
the competition or free flying. This can be applied to any
scenario hits you and then you are the most vulnerable to
losing it all. I think you've in many ways
answered most of the question. I think accumulated fatigue
gives you vulnerability. I think it gives you
vulnerability to poor decision making, to technical error, to
loss of concentration, to reduction in observation in all
of this stuff. Because as I said, the evidence
isn't perfect and it's very individual.
I frame it a bit differently. I frame it about giving yourself
margin. We do something that is
dangerous or potentially dangerous, and it's also
something that's not our job. We're not forced to do this, so
let's try and give ourselves the best possible margin.
And cumulative fatigue, which you're right will come from, if
you want to take confidence comps as an example, periods of
intense concentration, exposure to physical stressors like
hypoxia, poor sleep because you're in a new environment,
drinking because you're on holiday, and fair play to you,
but it will mess with your sleep.
All of those that fear, I guess if you have just the stress of
it, like all of those things will accumulate and reduce that
margin. So the question then is like,
how do I give myself the most margin?
And you do it by doing the opposite of those things, making
sure that you sleep well, managing your stress where you
can, the psychological side of stuff, reducing burdens of
decision making, checklists, body systems, all those things
being physically fit so you're not exhausted getting to launch
all of those things, build margin.
So rather than saying the science says that if you do XY
and Z, you will have a problem because I don't think we can
ever say that for an individual. I think we can apply common
sense to what would give anybody the best possible chance.
That's very interesting, but just to clarify, can accumulated
hypoxia also reach to lower levels of being hypoxic in days
to come? Because if you have been hypoxic
2 three to four days in a row, then fifth day you will be
hypoxic much more earlier than you would have been on day #1.
That's a really interesting question.
So in the short term, if you are hypoxic a little bit on one day
and then your hypoxy again the next day, you're probably not
going to be more or less hypoxic, but the effect of it
might be bigger because to your point, the day before was
fatiguing over a longer period of time.
This is obviously the process of acclimatisation where you are
hypoxic for a period of time and then your body starts to adapt
to that and it adapts through changes in breathing, It adapts
that through changes in fluids and through creating more red
blood cells so you can carry more oxygen.
But those accumulate those I guess changes take place over
days to weeks. And particularly in a
competition where you're sleeping at low altitudes so you
don't have an enormous kind of stimulus, I don't think that I
don't think a competition would be acclimatizing to altitude.
I don't think being hypoxic on day one of a comp and day 2
would make the hypoxia physiologically worse, but it
might make the effects worse. It might be more tiring.
I want to think about this from the perspective of people who
are gung ho on pushing it hard regardless of how difficult it
seems. And basically I'm trying to
understand the psychological side of these kind of Flyers.
So if you are somebody who wants to go out and chase the rush.
Now I do understand that I might be diving a bit into psychology
of free flight here, but let's say the chasing the rush part.
Is there a certain relatability to chasing the rush when it
comes to experiencing limits of your flight envelope versus
limits of your human existence and intoxication?
I'm not saying really question because it's.
Psychological. It's philosophical, it's moral.
It took me so. Long, but yeah, I get it.
Like it was hard to come up with it, but I'm glad you got the
vibe of it. Yeah, I've got some thoughts,
but I'm not sure I'm any more qualified than anyone else to
give them. Seeing as I'm a guest on the
podcast. I'll give it a go.
More generally, I think this psychological component of
paragliding vastly outweighs the physiological.
So this is a big shout out to my good friend, fabulous paraglider
pilot and current PhD student Jessica Love, who is just
finishing off a PhD on the psychology of fear and fear
injury in paragliding. It's fascinating and I think
will be much more impactful than anything I do.
To answer your question, though, there's a great book called
Dopamine Nation. Yeah, by a Stanford
psychologist. Now, I I bought that book
because I listened to her on a podcast and she talked in the
podcast about how she got addicted to teen romantic
fiction. And I was like, I'm buying you a
book. Now.
I don't know how that played out.
And in the Yeah, it turns out there's like just a really short
slippery slope from Twilight to werewolf porn that she tumbled
down. But the one of the really
interesting things that came out of that bit for me was that
there's very little research on drug of choice, as in why for
one person it's pushing the paragliding envelope, Why for
one person it's twilight. There's clearly a huge
biochemical overlap. Like it's it's triggering the
same stuff, dopamine, serotonin, noradrenaline, all of these kind
of neurotransmitters. But why one person gravitates to
one rather than the other is not very well understood based on
the book I read about the research.
In other words, not much knowledge.
It may be that there are some people who just have a higher
appetite for dopamine in general, and so to your point
would be chasing bits of paragliding that are at the
extremes as an alternative or alongside substance use.
Or it may be that people have a particular drug of choice and
that's paragliding rather than substance misuse.
But all of that is wrapped in people's social environment,
that upbringing, their view of the world, their kind of natural
characteristics. So I think it's a little bit
hard to say. I agree quickly.
What does Jessica Love's PhD about?
Because as you said, data sets are quite hard to come by and we
barely see anybody putting in that kind of effort.
And I would love to be in touch with her after we stop
recording. But you know, just an intro like
Fear Injury or what about it? Yeah, so I was texting Jess
Price this podcast and I was like, you're next, Jess.
Why not for sure? Yeah, because I think what Jess
has been doing is much more actually relevant to a pilot's
day-to-day than than what I do. I try and help around the edges.
The what her work is. This idea of fear injury, I
think has grew organically in our community.
Is it a term that you've heard? From Gavin, he throws it a lot
on his cloud based mayhem show. Yeah, exactly.
And when we try to chase it back, Jess and I, and we think
it actually came from, yeah, an episode of cloud based mayhem
where it was first heard in the wild.
Honestly, that is the. Only source of fear injury that
I've heard. There's no I never knew a fear
injury was a it could even fit in a sentence until I heard him
talking about it over a pair of years.
So I think everyone's source is gathered.
That's interesting, yeah. But I've had a bunch of people
talk about it now and I think it's like a lovely, it's a
lovely conception actually, because the idea of an injury to
me is something that can happen to anyone.
It's something that can be rehabilitated only if you do it
right and you have to put effort into rehabilitating it.
It doesn't just go away. And also maybe you can prevent
it in the same way that you can have injury prevention and you
have some people who are more susceptible to them.
Same way you can have a weak ankle joint, You can have be
more susceptible to fear injury, some who are less so.
I think it's a great concept for our sport and it certainly
overlaps with some with other more well known psychological
things like the twisties or the yips or the OR even things like
PTSD. But it's very definitely not the
same, but something that happens really just when you're
paragliding. And so Jess started looking into
this. And for those of you who don't
know Jess love, she's a highly experienced tandem pilot, spent
a lot of time in Nepal, done a lot of comps.
She current she's currently there meet director for the
shower open. Yeah, very kind of somebody
who's been very not only paragliding has been a whole
part of her life, but is very embedded in the community.
So Jess started trying to understand what fear injury was,
come up with a really good definition, got to that was her
first bit of work. Her second bit of work was about
how it changes in individuals over time.
How does it evolve when someone is there a good route out?
Are there some people who get trapped in it?
And then her last bit of work that she's just finished is just
doing things like SIV, change somebody's susceptibility to
fear injury. So this is a teaser for that.
If you want to know what she found, we'll get her next.
But it's great work. It's something that she's
devoted kind of mind, body and soul to for the last four years
and we're very lucky to have her enough support.
Fascinating, fascinating, and definitely it's on the she's on
the next guest list for the episodes upcoming.
So to anybody who's listening, stay tuned, stay excited.
As I always say, this magic is just getting started.
Absolutely. Matt, you, you have been
expedition doctor as well. I was just like browsing over
you. I think you're one of those few
para mining pilots who can be googled up and there are endless
search results that you can binge on to see what this pilot
has been off to. But as.
Long as there are no court records.
They're all clean, but what do you say?
Any experience? Like, how does your life look
like when you're out and about in the wild and, you know, just
just being out there making real money rather than just flying
for a hobby? So I think it's debatable how
much money I've made out of expedition medicine.
It's another thing done for the love.
I was really fortunate when I was a student that I got the
opportunity to go to Bolivia as a Guinea pig on a altitude
science study run by this group called the Apex Collaboration,
which is based out of Edinburgh and was a hilarious trip because
we were doing the first randomised controlled trial of
Viagra for prevention of lung altitude illness.
So it meant you had all these students that got stuck in a
bus, driven up to five and a half, 1000 meters, half taking
Viagra, half taking a placebo, everyone criminally else.
She's sick. And some of those couples are
still together. Now wait a second.
I don't get it. You put couples and gave them
Viagra and drove up to 5000 meters?
What? Like how?
Why? Science and India Science.
So the thing about Viagra is it wasn't originally designed for
what we all know it for so well. It was originally designed to
relax the smooth muscle in the lung, the pulmonary artery,
which carries blood from the heart to the lung.
Because in some people that pulmonary artery gets really
tight and compressed and the blood backs up and it stretches
the heart and they get heart failure.
And so the idea behind Viagra was that it was a drug that
would relax that pulmonary artery.
And it was only really when testing it that they discovered
a extremely lucrative side effect, which is what we all now
know it for. In altitude illness,
particularly altitude illness that leads to high altitude
pulmonary edema or HAPE, you have the same problem where you
get an increase in pulmonary artery pressure.
And so the thinking went, and it's quite sensible thinking
that if you take Viagra, you will reduce the pulmonary artery
pressure because that's what it's designed for.
And people would be less likely to develop altitude illness of
the lung. Now interestingly doesn't seem
to work. Variants on Viagra are still in
some of the guidelines and the American guidelines in
particular, but really not that helpful for something that
should be textbook perfect for altitude.
But this, and I can't tell you why, but this experience for me
was very eye opening because I realised one, altitude is
fascinating and two, there's some semblance of a career that
can be made within medicine and research where you get to go
outside and climb mountains. And so that was what kind of set
me off down this path. And I've been lucky enough my
kind of core specialty is anesthesia and critical care
medicine, but I've been lucky enough to spend more time out of
the hospital than in working up at high altitude, particularly
in Nepal, a little bit in India. And so it's great because it
means that all the stuff I read about and doing the lab, you get
to see and some of the lessons I can bring back to paragliding.
COVID kind of killed a lot of that for me.
So it was all going quite well until February 2020 when I
thought, oh, I don't have to go back to the hospital.
I have enough. This altitude expedition will
feed and clothe me. That came to a crashing halt in
March 2020. I was very lucky.
I got to go back to work in my local hospital.
So I did that for wave 1 of COVID and then now I work online
for a remote care company and that at least has the advantage
of being very flexible in terms of where I work my hours, which
is great for going flying and for travelling around the world
to some of the lovely spots where we go flying.
I still keep one day a week where I do altitude and cold
research through the Extreme Environments Lab at the
University of Portsmouth, and that's also where Jess is
enrolled as a student. So I used to do it all the time.
Someone ate a bat, caused COVID, ruined my life.
But I've fallen on my feet and I now get to visit these places as
a tourist and still do a little bit of research.
It sounds fancy to say that I'm a tourist at Extreme
Environments Lab. The name itself sounds so cool.
It's a great place. They do amazing stuff.
Actually. There are cold water labs.
So they grew out of the Institute of Naval Medicine and
they've done an enormous amount of work around why young people
drown. They've really, that's the kind
of core specialty. And then I came and just as they
were expanding from a cold water lab to a lab that focuses on
lots of different stressors. So things like epoxy, a cold
heat, sleep deprivation, and how they will interact.
And then I came along and said we should look at paragliding.
And so I was able to do a little bit of work through them on the
paragliding and then I helped support all the other more
general stuff. So what's the paragliding side
of the lab that you? So the paragliding side, the
lab, we've done a few things through that.
We've created a simulator where we got a paragliding harness,
put it in an environmental chamber and created hypoxia,
cold and headland. And we got pilots to do a
simulated flight up to 3 1/2 thousand meters and do cognitive
tests. And what I found from that was a
complete muddle, which comes back to what I said at the
beginning, which is that it was a really small group of people.
And sure, like when they got up high, they were less good at the
cognitive tests. Their reaction time changed.
They weren't very good at stacking blocks and all the
things that we had them do. But what that told me about how
well somebody would thermal or whether they'd fly into the
Cliff or not, I think it's impossible to say.
And that was as much kind of my growth as a researcher going
through that process is anything that contributed to paragliding.
But what came out of it was this realisation that if we want to
learn stuff in paragliding, we need to focus on really specific
things. Like what I've done in that
chamber was too general. And So what I then did next was
say, OK, the thing that kills paragliders is hitting the
ground. What stops paraglide is hitting
the ground. The reserve parachute is
probably the last line of defence.
Why don't people throw the reserve parachute?
And so then I started doing the work that I think has been most
useful for paragliding, which was around reserves, how we need
to be different, why people do or don't throw them.
Fascinating. I'm very tempted to ask, could
you please tell us what that research was about and what have
the findings been so far? Yeah, sure.
We did two things. We got 55 pilots and took them
to a zip line and we put them on a zip line and we got them to do
a cognitive challenge. So they looked up at 2 flashing
lights. They had to pull their brake
lines along with kind of flashing lights, and we got them
to say all the things that could come up, beginning with a
certain letter. The idea being that the hands
were engaged, their eyes were in a position as if they were
fixing a wing, and we'd give them a cognitive challenge.
Then they were released down the zip line and they had to throw
their reserve parachute as fast as possible, so they had to make
a cognitive switch. We then from that work, we then
went to the G Force simulator at Frutschler Hocheries in German,
who were wonderful people. Jess Barlow there, who ran at
the time, was so helpful. And we repeated the same model
with 83 pilots, but this time they're in rotation forwards and
backwards between sort of two and 4G.
And the reason why I think this was useful work was because for
once in one of these studies, we had enough people and we were
looking at something really specific.
And So what we found was that, first of all, pilots look for
their reserve handle along their skeleton.
So if they're rotating forwards, their hand naturally goes to
their hip bone. If they're rotating backwards,
as they would in a sat or an auto rotation, they go a bit
further down their thigh. But when the reserve handle
wasn't in those places, you could see people just repeatedly
tapping all around trying to find it.
We also found that pilots would naturally pull up on the reserve
handle even if the reserve was designed to be pulled outwards.
We found that they needed to grip it in a particular way.
And all of these things gave us design suggestions for how a
reserve handle should be because what we found in the studies
consistently is that when people had a problem, they couldn't
innovate, like they couldn't fix it under stress.
So that to me means that our kit has to work for us.
We can't expect someone to. If you tell somebody what you
need to do, if you're need to throw your reserve as you need
to put yourself into Batfly, you need to find your reserve
handle, you need to throw it towards your feet.
All the stuff that people say, all of that's true, I'm sure,
but the average person can't do that even in a simulated
environment. There's just so much going on
that we need to make it easy for people.
And I would say there's been like mixed uptake from the
research. Like I made some videos that
show all of this online, can send you the link, wrote to the
manufacturers, wrote to the EM committee.
They adopted some of the recommendations and some of the
new harnesses like supper. The supper ones were great.
The new, it might be the advanced one.
The new advanced one is beautiful.
It has a really nice big chunky handle.
It's just on the hip. All of this stuff is wonderful.
The little tiny strings that you see on some of them are clearly
less in tune with what the average pilot does.
But we've made some progress and particularly reserve containers,
like most reserves now, you can pull them out at any angle.
So I really like that work because I thought it was robust,
it was repeatable. We did it on lots of people.
We came up with recommendations that were concrete and that we
could change to make our sport better.
So the Chamber study at Portsmouth was good to do
because it led to this stuff. I wouldn't necessarily take all
that I found from that and base your life.
The question that comes to our mind is that when like XR7 EXO
seed, every other reserve handle is generally at your hip, and
then suddenly we move to submarine style where it's a
game changer. It's right in front of you.
So there is definitely a visual sense sensory input that is
coming to you that is saying that, hey, there it is.
So no matter how much you're panicking, it's very hard to
miss out. But as a pilot or as an end
user, when you're switching your equipment, is it worth it?
Or is it not worth risking your life?
That's such a good question and I love that you came to that as
well because when I went into the reserve studies, I was like
front mount is going to be better, obviously going to be
better. It's right in front, but what we
found was that there was no difference in the time it took
people to locate a front mounted reserve compared to a hip
mounted one. But what we did see is lots of
people with front mounted reserves slapping their hip
because that's what they used to have.
Your point about changing gear is profound and so I went in
thinking front mount is best. I came out thinking actually I
don't really mind, but you need to pick one thing and stick with
it because when you swap between the two, that's where you're
going to have a problem. And I took that on board.
So I fly an air design sock which has got a front mount and
I have made sure that I have a front mounted set up for my hike
and fly gear as well. I think yeah, because what you
said that make a choice and stick to it.
Like I have been flying XR7 for the longest time and to be
honest, I feel so at home in that harness because I know
where and how my body, where it is touching to the harness, how
it feels and everything. So I think consistency of
something as important as that, like your seat, which is
basically defining how you're going to make all the decisions
depending on how comfortable you are, is like such an important
part. So definitely I think this is
what every listener should have in their mind that when they
make an investment, which is fairly difficult, do I guess
it's not that easy to invest that kind of money.
Make sure it is something that you want and not something that
you would like to sell and then move on to something else and
then retune your brain wiring system until you get used to it.
I think that's true. And I think if we're honest
about why we make the kit decisions, we make them because
of newness and kind of social environment.
We make them because of cost, weight, aerodynamics, safety, I
think falls down the chain a little bit.
And I don't know. This is again where I slightly
despair of the competition scene because I come back to this,
that people in comps aren't paid and no one knows who you are
except for the other people in comps.
And if everybody's got a submarine, no one has an
advantage for flying a submarine.
So why not all agree to fly something that has decent back
protection and an easy to access reserve container?
But as I say, that's just me. I think maybe if I was a bit
more competitively minded I might think.
Like what you said makes complete sense.
The whole idea of flying the top equipment is to gain the extra
edge, but if that is negated by the whole field being upgraded,
then what's the point of risking the upgrade?
Exactly, and that's why I think SRS is such a nice way to do
competitions. Brett is a difficult man to get
hold of these days. He's super busy with the good.
More competition, more. SRS.
Yeah, Matt, there's a lot we can keep on bouncing our thoughts
back and forth. And especially I would like to
just put this out in public domain again, that there is so
much material from Matt that is available on how to in depth
things on how to make sure that you're not hypoxic or cold
exposure or even the first aid kit, which I think there are
quite a few videos that you've done with few creators which are
explaining that in depth. So just Google up Matt Doctor,
Matt Wykes paragliding and you will see endless knowledge to
binge on. But if we quickly have to touch
upon the topic of first aid, I'm going to take the worst case
layman scenario because I think somehow, including me, a lot of
pilots are susceptible to falling in this where they're
like, it won't happen to me. So let me just go out and fly
with whatever I have and let me focus on that rather than do the
homework and whatever it takes. As you said, safety takes a
backseat for some reason. And that is another very
interesting psychological effect.
But let's say you're a pilot who has gone out.
All by himself, very little contact with the outside world
except the radio and the emergency whatever you can
scurry off last minute. What does your first aid look
like when you don't have a first aid kit in your back?
I think it's your in reach, it's what your first aid looks like.
One of the like interesting things about Paradigm First Aid,
which is why I find it fascinating and what I've delved
into it is most first aid stuff is either kind of first aid at
work, which is designed for cities and it's designed for.
I've splashed this in my eye or I've cut myself or I've fallen
off a ladder or it comes out of military stuff and military
stuff is really first aid is one has some very specific injuries,
ballistic injuries, but also it's very much part of an
organised chain. Military first aid assumes that
a bunch of other things are going to happen in rapid
succession. Someone's going to get picked up
and shipped out. So paragliding first aid then
becomes this kind of really interesting hybrid.
It's a bit like what we said at the beginning about how you have
to cherry pick your evidence from other sources.
And sometimes, as you say, we fly alone, but more often we fly
in small groups with friends and we fly in remote places.
So if an accident happens, then the people who are first on
scene are either you, the person who has had the accident, or
your friends. And they often have to be there
for quite a long time, and they need to look after things that
are quite serious. And the environments themselves
and the rescue services aren't necessarily predictable.
So it's not like first aid at work in a city, and it's not
like military injuries. So then the question is, what
general principles can we apply under those circumstances that
will be helpful and won't make things anything worse?
And so a lot of it for me is really about organization
because to your point about if you're on your own, you don't
have any kit, what can you do? We can get someone to come to
you who does. So when I think about managing
an accident or how we should think about managing an
accident, the first thing that we need to do when an accident
happens is establish who we have and establish A-Team.
So what you sometimes see in accidents is as an accident,
everyone stands back and suddenly everyone rushes to the
casualty, then no one knows what to do and then suddenly a
functional team will emerge. But we need to short circuit
that and become a functional team straight away.
So that's where talking to your friends, you say, not ignoring
safety side of things, talking to your friends about what will
happen if there's an accident, mentally rehearsing these
things, all of that stuff that helps short circuit that process
and establish A functional team. So it's functional team, it's
making the scene safe, so securing the wing, not tumbling
down, not landing in exactly the same place as where the other
pilot landed. So the same thing that can
happen to you. All of the things to make sure
that you are an effective rescue team, not extra casualties.
Then locate the pilot, find safe access to them, secure them so
they, the pilot don't fall down a Cliff or fall out of a tree
and get help. And there's been a million
podcasts and things about how to get help, and it depends where
you are, but just making sure you have multiple means of
communication, phones, radios in reach, whatever is appropriate
to where you are. So everything's secured, you're
safe, the pilot is physically safe, and help is on the way.
Then the next thing is that if they're bleeding, obviously work
to stop it. That's most effectively done
through applying direct pressure to the bleeding.
In certain circumstances, tourniquets are the right thing
to do. Again, huge discussions, but
these are just the big principles.
Stop the bleeding and then do all the usual first aid stuff,
assessing them for their airway, their breathing, their
circulation, all of that stuff. But the thing that's different
here is protect them from the environment.
We've talked a lot about cold and hypoxia and all those
things. Keeping somebody warm, dry, out
of the wind reduces their chance of death.
It makes their blood clot more effectively if they're not cold.
It reduces their energy requirements, it makes them less
fearful and adrenaline ridden. So really work to make somebody
comfortable. But that might mean the harness
is quite good because insulation from the ground, but it might
mean wrapping them in the wing. It might mean sometimes dragging
them behind a rock if you have to.
It might mean drying them off. Like all of these things to keep
them comfortable, reassure them if you're going to move them
gently and move them once planned, think ahead and then
look after them as you would want to be looked after
yourself. That's I think sometimes the
best guidance. When people say like, how do I
develop judgement? We develop judgement through
experience. If you don't have the
experience, then all you can do is draw on what you do have and
think, if I was in this position, what would I want done
for me? Go ahead.
But to sum up, establish A-Team, locate the pilot, make sure the
scene is safe for you, secure them, get help, stop bleeding,
and then protect them from the environment.
That's such words full of wisdom.
Dark. I think the way you put it out
was the most professional way. In 5 minutes of a podcast
section we could have covered it.
She had done that at the beginning.
People would have to listen to all the other nonsense, me
telling you I don't know and there wasn't any science.
I can put this in a trailer, we can keep the listeners tuned
like for the best for the last kind of a bit.
But before I close on to this topic, Doc adrenaline is such a
superpower in these situations. How to make the most optimum use
of the adrenaline that will come, the spike of adrenaline
that will come after the impact for the next First of all, how
long does that spike last? And secondly, how to make the
most effective use of it, because that is the time you're
feeling the least pain. Yeah, I think it's both helpful
and unhelpful in the sense that it's helpful because you're
feeling the least pain, but it can be unhelpful because you
might do stuff assuming that you're fine.
So it's the classic thing of somebody who breaks their leg
and then stands up and makes the break much worse.
So the spike of adrenaline, I think if you have the presence
of mind, is best used by getting yourself to a safe place and
calling for help. It can be used by those around
you to do the same thing on your behalf, get you to a safe place
and call for help. After a while though, adrenaline
stops being helpful because adrenaline causes metabolic load
that makes your heartbeat faster.
It puts demands on your body when you're injured.
So that's why once you've done the immediate stuff, keeping
somebody warm, comfortable, being reassuring to them, giving
them simple painkillers, giving them a little bit of food and
water if that's appropriate. If you're there for a long time,
by all means give some and their awaken can ask for it.
By all means, give them food and water, all of those comfort
things you've made use of the spike, but now it's actually
about reducing that adrenaline and keeping people calm and
relaxed because that's what will help them long time.
I would like to throw back on my postal experience.
When I deploy it, I had like more than 50%, I don't know,
607080 or asymmetric cascade, double twisted auto rotation and
eventually landed in a tree. By that time my hands were
frosted like crazy. They were like freezing, in
fact, when the collapse happened, which was probably the
reason why I couldn't really stop it.
But when I was in the tree, when everything calmed down, when it
was nothing but quiet, like everything was silent, I just
said that you know what? Let me just soak in what
happened. So I just like stayed there, I
don't know for how many minutes, but until I could feel my hands
again. So it could be like, I don't
know, four or five or something like that.
And that kind of course to let my heart rate come down, but I
think it did bleed off the adrenaline away from the body as
well. So is staying put and just
getting a breather one of the best things?
Like doing nothing is the best way to do the right thing as
well in these situations. Hell yes, hell yes, because the
worst thing you could do under that circumstance would be
unbucky your harness and fall out of it and fall out of a
tree. So one of the best pieces of
advice I was given by a senior doctor was don't just do
something, man, stand there. So the opposite of don't just
stand there, do something. It's that idea of take some
time, soak in what's happened, think about your options and
make the right decision. And actually and actually what's
interesting in there is it's not always easy to do that.
That shows a lot about your experience and presence of mind
that you were able to take that pause and then do the thing that
was right under the circumstances.
Psychologically, it's also been shown that if you're able to
integrate the experience and understand why something
happened, then you're less likely to find it traumatising
afterwards. So 100% the right thing to do.
Even when we're talking about first aid before that idea of so
one of these other sort of things that people used to
remember 10 for 1010 seconds for pause, for 10 minutes for the
net to plan the next 10 minutes is a really sensible thing to do
to make sure that no, no further time is wasted by indecision or
doing the wrong thing. So 100% the right thing to do.
Well done. I can see how you might have had
some adrenaline though after all of that.
You have no idea. There was a time like, yeah, I
mean, I deployed, so that was like the last for that.
It'll do something. Otherwise life as well cease to
exist. So the spikes were high as hell.
But it's amazing how many people don't.
That's why I got so interested in that and the research because
that is the deploying your reserve is the single best thing
you can do to save your life if you are too low or in an
unrecoverable situation. But people don't, I think quite
a lot about this. And I think some of it is
potentially, you know, ergonomic as we've touched on, like they
just can't find the handle under the circumstances.
But a lot of it, I think is this idea of loss aversion.
We hate to as humans, we would rather not lose something than
gain something. It's this kind of heuristic.
It's a psychological trait of humans.
And so we know that if you throw a reserve, you're going to lose
some stuff. You're going to your flights,
definitely done, you're going to have to repack it, you might end
up in a tree. And so I think we just try and
avoid that loss for ages. We try and fix things and we
carry on and we carry on. Whereas the obvious gain is if
you say save your life, sometimes I think under these
circumstances people struggle to make that switch.
So again, speaks to your presence of mind.
The other thing I wanted to pick up on because it was a great
point, was your point about not being able to manage the
collapse because you had cold hands.
I think where it came down to that thing we were saying about
underestimating the environment, like I think we really need to
be switched on about caring for our hands because when our hands
get cold, we lose fine motor dexterity.
So we lose again feeling of that imminent collapse, potentially
the ability to fix it or through a reserve.
It's cognitively distracting, but brain energy instead of
making all the decisions is being directed to my hands are
cold. And finally you can do long term
damage to your hands repeated like frosties screaming barfies,
whatever you call it damages the nerves and blood vessels of the
hands, which means you then get it more frequently and
ultimately you can end up with permanent pins and needles or
loss of feeling. So I think one things that I've
become very conscious of is caring for my hands when I fly.
And we're in a terrible position for you because they're exposed
to the airflow like all the blood drains from them.
They're wrapped around the top of your brake handles.
So we're very vulnerable. And one of the best ways to do
it again is keeping a really warm core.
But otherwise, there's no perfect solution.
Piece of gloves, down sleeves, whatever works for you, but
paying attention to keeping the warm I think is really
important. Thank you for pointing that out,
Doc. I missed that one.
I'm so glad you picked up on that one.
But coming to the reserve party, before we close, I want to ask
your opinion on this. Does this relate to the
self-confidence levels in life? And I'll give you an example
that why my thought process is going that direction.
For example, somebody comes out and roasts you.
Now you have to bring out your defense mechanism.
And this might sound unrelated, but just stay with me for a SEC.
I'm here for it. For it.
So a response to a roast will come much more successfully if
you are more confident and happier in your life because you
know how to stand up for yourself.
Similarly, if you are generally more confident in your flying,
then the response to a collapse that the answer is a reserved
throw will come much more confidently I believe rather
than if you are just like jittery about you're flying and
you don't know like does that make any relation or sense?
Because to me it does. Yeah, it's interesting.
I suppose the, if you were to put a counterpoint to that, are
you more likely to throw a reserve if you're jittery or if
you so confident in your SIB skills that you think you can
fix it? But more broadly, I think your
point is interesting. And I, I suppose what I would
take from that is the importance of creating a positive training
environment for pilots. So I guess when I look at
paragliding culture, there's quite a lot of comparison stick,
isn't there? There's there's people who are
very positive about what flying means.
There's also those perhaps who've had bad experiences
themselves who focus on the negative or who focus on
performance rather than progress.
And so I think if we want to create a positive environment in
the sport, it's about growing people and encouraging them to
do things like SIV to throw their reserve if they need to.
And no one will say to them, you're an idiot, you threw your
reserve. Somebody decides not to fly
because conditions are too much for them and they decided to
walk down being like, well done, great choice, all within
moderation. But doing things like that, I
think to your point, could build people up or give them the best
again margin possible to use their skills in the best way at
the right time. I mean, my part about confidence
was that it just helps you be more decisive.
So if you're confident, then you're decisive in your actions,
be it like coming back to the roast or coming back to the
decision that do I throw or do I not throw.
But if you're under confident, then the indecisiveness just
lingers on a tiny bit longer and that is where you're losing
critical seconds which could be make or break totally.
Agree with that and there's some very interesting research
actually that you're a bit like your roast point.
Your kind of confidence depends on the environment that you're
in. So if you're with a group of
pilots and you're the best pilot there, you are more likely to be
overconfident and take risks, so you're more vulnerable.
If you're the worst pilot, you're likely to be under
confident, doubt yourself and underperform relative to your
average skills. So there's vulnerability at both
ends there. None of us.
I'm so glad I asked. I just came to my mind on the
flight. But doc, I can completely
understand. We are running way beyond our
time limit. This has been more insightful
than what I thought it would be and I'm very thankful that you
have given us all of those things.
But before I let you go, Doc, one flight that has stuck with
you which you can't pick out from your carrier.
I'm always very curious to ask this question to my guest
because the answers are vividly creative and amazing and wild
all at the same time. It's so hard, isn't it?
Because I was thinking that it's like the Desert Island Discs
thing. What would you take?
And when you said what's the most memorable flight I thought
of, I had four that came immediately to them.
I think the one that springs to mind is I live in the Highlands,
and the Highlands have a mountain range called the
Cairngorms in the middle. And I live on the West side.
And on a particular day, we were flying on the east side and I
was flying with a bunch of pilots who were better than me.
I didn't have my normal wing with me.
I was on a really old raggedy swift.
And for some reason I just fell on it that day.
And, and everybody was flying and they were flying a triangle.
And I suddenly thought, I think I can cross the Cairngorms, like
I think I can fly to my house. And so I set off a kind of
perpendicular to everybody else and started flying across the
Cairngorms. And I got a third of the way
across and was like, oh God. This wasn't a good.
Idea I'm like, if I land here, I'm going to be like 2 days late
for because they're quite icy. But I bobbed along and I if I
made it over to the other side and I nearly made it to my
house. And I think the reason why I
loved it so much was so many things came together.
It was flying, something that I'd always wanted to do in a
place that to me is very special and very beautiful.
But also it was the culmination of a lot of years of slowly
building skills that meant that I was able to put things
together and make that happen. So that was a wonderful thing.
But equally, anytime I've flown tandem with anyone, I've always
loved like sharing. Sharing a flight with somebody
is almost always more joyful. Than testing on your.
The most meaningful value comes from sharing your passion.
I completely agree with that one.
Not beyond words. Powerful for sure, but even.
So that's what's yours. Have you said?
Oh. Shit, no, come on, don't ask me
that. Well, I was not prepared for
this. Yeah, man, you did, you know,
reversed. What is your?
What's your favorite? Bring it on.
Come on. Without thinking too much.
You know what? I'm so tempted to just give you
the flight that I was thinking about because living in Oslo,
there is a flight that you get to fly over the city, and I live
on the other side from the takeoff point.
And one of these. Yeah.
But more than that, I was going to say that to complete my
sentence, Like one of these flights where I just bobbed over
the city where I was having similar questions.
Like shit man, if I land, I have to look for a soccer field
because it's otherwise it's trams and buses and roads.
And if I land on any, even if I land for like normal, I will be
pulled up by the authorities and it'll be a lot of shame around
it. That why did you Outland?
But hands down one of the most spectacular flights that I've
had is big mountains in beer billing when I did the upper
Ridge from beer to Dharamsala. Holy freaking moly man that.
Just that wall, just that wall that you go by when you do that
flow. Nothing else comes close man.
The mightiest, the grandest, the most majestic, every single
element which makes you go fuck is this even real is condensed
into one and you are living it real time.
Shit. Let me say one more and I know
this is not the rule. You have to pick one, but.
I snuck the tandems in. Fair enough, yes, then I should
get this fast as well. So both Bulgaria I was flying
last year. This is baffling to me.
So here is the Ridge, right? This is the take off and I take
off from here. On this side of the Ridge, the
clouds are towering at least 1500 meters higher than the
clouds on this side. I don't know what the system is
by the way, I'm going to come out with the wing review video
within a week or two, so stay tuned on the channel.
Every single detail of this flight is coming out and it will
show you how spectacular it was. So what I do is I take off, I
circle out in these clouds and then I go fly above this cloud
layer which is on the other side of the bank.
And I was like, I can do this all day.
And I was just like, beyond what's fascinating.
And I was the only parallelizer in at least 100 kilometer radius
that day which was able to experience this.
That's amazing. Sometimes those cloud formations
just blow your mind. That is, it was insane like how
does one weather systems stick on this side of the Ridge and
the other weather system is just like booming with thermals up to
thousand 1500 meters on the other end, so.
Yeah, imagine that's a humbling thing to the guy in the sky.
I'll send you the link and to the audiences.
Stay tuned. This is one of the most
beautiful, except the dollar dars and the mighty Himalayas.
So life is a blessing when you're in the air or the
otherwise. Yeah.
That's a perfect note to end on. Yeah, exactly.
Agree with that. Doc, how can I say thank you?
I'm out of words, but I hope you get my wife.
It was an honor having you here and there was only so many
topics we could touch upon. But I'm so glad we did, and all
I can say is, until next time, let's do this again.
Thank you so much for having me.